compensatory draft picks also a big part
of the process the nfl yesterday
announcing 36 compensatory picks that
will go to 17 teams the patriots get the
highest of the compensatory picks 96th
overall in the third round they lost tom
brady jamie collins kyle van noy among
others last year and this is all
determined by and it's a complicated
formula i think anybody understands
although the ravens have cracked the
code on this long ago free agency losses
free agency gains during a certain
window
they crunch the numbers after the fact
and they determine the compensatory
picks so that's something the patriots
have mastered yeah free agents leave
they let them leave they trade for guys
with a year left on their contracts like
they're getting with trent brown
calculating this idea that if the guy
walks away we get a gain on the back end
in the form of a compensatory draft pick
definitely and and you know not only
okay you get a chance of course to draft
extra guys there and you know the top
110 picks of the draft so there's some
value there as we see every year there's
you know yeah it's it's not the elite of
the elite but you can certainly find
your diamonds in the rough there and the
other big thing too where
you know at a year like this you know
new england's got some more toys to play
with if they want to trade up in the
draft or make a drastic move those are
picks that teams are going to look at
and go what you'll give us the 96 pick
and this to move up you know five spots
or whatever else it's going to come in
handy and that's why they're new england
they crack every code there is in the
history of football
once upon a time compensatory picks
could not be traded two three years ago
that rule changed so they can move
around with those compensatory picks and
they're going to have the dollars in
free agency they can go bargain shopping
and that's surely what they will do that
roster could undergo a lot of change as
these guys become available who aren't
signed by other teams who aren't getting
the money they're looking for if you can
convince guys to sign on to the patriot
way which uh has one day of fun per year
the day you get your super bowl ring two
days of fun three days the day you win
the super bowl the day you have the
parade the day you get your ring it's
not that's 360. 362 days of work work
work work work um the cowboys have the
most compensatory picks this year with
four they lost cornerback byron jones
and linebacker robert quinn among others
last year
four teams getting compensatory picks
this year for the first time
due to the new effort by the nfl to
encourage teams to develop minority
candidates whether it's assistant
coaches or executives if they're hired
by other teams
that's when you get the competitory pick
remember a year ago they were thinking
about giving teams compensatory picks
for making the higher
the end result is you get the pick for
having your employee
get hired 49ers they actually will have
multiple picks over the next few years
this year just one though the
combination of the hiring of robert
salad by the jets martin mayhew by
washington right right
rams lost brad holmes to the lions he's
the gm there ravens lost david cully he
was the receivers coach he goes to
houston as the head coach and then in
new orleans terry fontenot he became the
gm of the falcons the falcons gave their
rivals an extra draft pick by making
that higher that tells you what they
thought of terry fontenot and there are
those picks in that range chris of 102
to 105 and as pete pointed out he did
the research some great players over the
years have been found there including in
that range
a certain kirk cousins yeah yeah era
i love him today
i'm just stating a fact that i know i'm
just stating a fact no but you're right
some days depending upon my mood i would
say that's a reason not to have a pick
in 102 to
yeah but but there are some good names
on there with us devonte freeman hey
daryl williams the right tackle is a
free agent from buffalo right now he's
gonna get paid trey hendrickson the pass
rusher on the scene so you know your
backup running back on your minnesota
vikings alexander madison there's value
there yeah your team baby
but
but
i
you know
this thing with the you know the
minority hiring and all that
you know listen i i i
i like it it's giving teams incentives
to push guys too
now you know you know it's it's going to
be on the other teams to go wait is he
worthy of that really okay we got to dig
through this or is this team you know
trying to trick us so they can get a
compensatory pick either way
it's pushing names and people out there
into the conversation that might not
have been pushed out there if it weren't
for this what i i have been accused
accurately from time to time for being
cynical but that is an ultracynical view
that a team would willingly lose a
valued employee to get a draft pick well
if they don't think he's that valuable
they might do that
so hey
is the guy how about this watch i really
love this watch i can't part with this
watch oh you want this watch boy that's
a shame hey i'm a big martin mayhew brad
holmes fan
all of that too i hear you you know it
creates an incentive it does it's an
incentive right that's the problem
with this little twist in the rules is
the nfl tries desperately
to
to enhance the hiring of minority
executives as general managers assistant
coaches as head coaches that this is
this is part of of the reality and
frankly i thought
that it would become harder
for candidates who are with other teams
especially executives gm's you know
because
rick smith
jerry reese
louis riddick
three
available minority executives who could
have been hired to be a general manager
and nobody gets
any draft pick compensation because
they're unattached i thought they had an
advantage
in this environment so i think it
it tells you that
you're gonna hire the best person for
the job even if it means giving one of
your arch rivals a compensatory draft
pick that for whatever reason
of all that you know that no one was
swayed by
okay well you know
this possibility that you're going to
enhance someone else's draft day we're
going to go get the best candidates and
if it means someone's getting a
compensatory pick so be it yeah agreed i
think there's that angle and then
you know hey look at terry fontenot i
mean all i hear is good things about the
guy i've only met him in passing i don't
really know him or anything like that
but you know those guys too
when they are really good at their job
teams will squash them a little bit
because they don't want them to get out
of the building and do that so now this
is like you know hey wait he's really
good let's i don't want to give him too
many avenues to get out of here and do
those type of things now it gets them
out there so i think there is you know
it's proven that there is a little value
here for sure and uh i do like that
because we know this is a big problem in
the nfl
but you know you put yourself in brad
holmes and terry fontenot's shoes during
the process
there had to have been a concern that
i'm going to get passed over because of
the fact that a compensatory draft pick
flows to my team if i get higher right
and uh there there had to have been some
angst and some concern
but you know at the end of the day
and i think this is
the refreshing aspect of it that at
their core i think that nfl teams
want the best people for the jobs
they just they need more coaching they
need more guidance they need more effort
instead of locking on and i think this
has been the problem over the years you
have an owner who locks onto a name
locks on to a reputation locks onto a
camera
and and doesn't let go and never has
that that broader effort to take a step
back and say am i truly getting the best
person for this job at this moment yeah
right or they lock on to an advisor
who only advises them to go after the
six guys he's friends with in the nfl
you know that's the other thing that the
owners fall into the trap with so
yeah there's some value to this and
you're right that's the other side of
the story too where
you know the compensatory pick some
teams might not want to see other teams
get that and do that but uh all in all
hey look
from that standpoint it looks pretty
good i wish we had more minority head
coach hiring certainly i still don't
understand the eric b enemy one and all
of that but i will say this and i'll
stick up for the nfl they're trying to
do right here and trying to make this
right and i give him credit for that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports